in the mood for a good laugh well you
could always check out some big bunch of
comedy everybody's seen a million times
or you could dig a bit deeper and find
something funny that's been swept under
the cinematic rug if you want to try
something a bit more obscure keep
watching to discover some hysterical
comedies that flew completely under the
radar after hours in 1985 legendary
director Martin Scorsese
created one of the weirdest comedies to
ever come from a mainstream filmmaker an
oddball movie called after hours griffin
dunne plays a guy named Paul Hackett who
just wants to get a ride home after a
date in New York City but instead he
finds himself lost in the twisted Wizard
of Oz universe version of the Big Apple
where everyone else seems to have gone
completely bonkers it all plays out like
an eerily funny fever dream or some
long-lost Lewis Carroll novel where
there are no rules and you should avoid
everyone you meet because they're all
stark raving mad with nail and I comedy
isn't always just about the laughs for
proof look no further the 1987's with
nail and eye a dark British comedy that
reeks of weed wine and desperation Paul
McGann and Richard e Graham play two
struggling actors who take a vacation in
the country to get their head straight
fill with quotable lines and hilarious
hijinks with nail and eye is also a
deeply sad film about struggling with
addiction and finding yourself trapped
in life with nowhere to go but down
don't worry though it's still funny
with Time Out London ranking it at
number seven on its countdown of the 100
best comedies ever made the Brothers
Bloom
Ryan Johnson is best known for films
like brick looper and Star Wars the last
Jedi but he's also responsible for the
criminally underrated comedy the
Brothers Bloom a delightful romp full of
confidence games double crosses and a
lot of nitroglycerin narrated by the
great Ricky Jay the Brothers Bloom might
be a bit too quirky for some but if you
don't mind the fantastical style stars
Mark Ruffalo Adrien Brody and Rachel
vice deliver performances that are
incredibly fun to watch Plus like any
good con movie it does a great job of
constantly making you wonder if you're
in on the game or if you're actually
being played macGruber inspired by the
Saturday Night Live sketch macGruber
finds Will Forte sporting a mullet
saving America and fighting weird new
ways to use celery sticks the film was a
massive flop when it came out in 2010
and was eviscerated by critics but may
years since this
of 1980s action flicks has found a cult
following even Christopher Nolan is a
fan telling Business Insider there are
scenes that had him howling
uncontrollably raunchy bloody and stupid
and equal measures this one is simply
classic macGruber Tucker and Dale vs.
evil
if the horror genre has taught us
anything it's that you can't trust a
hillbilly it seems these backwood
bumpkins are always looking for preppy
kids to chop into tiny pieces right well
2010's Tucker and Dale vs. evil flips
this idea on its head turning the
mountain men into lovable lugs just
trying to help a group of vacationing
college kids who are so terrified by
horror movie stereotypes about rednecks
that they keep accidentally killing
themselves that'll ease Tucker and Dale
vs. evil hilarious it actually has an
important message good job guys
everybody wants some directed by Richard
Linklater 2016's everybody wants some
has been hailed as the spiritual sequel
to Linklaters classic Dazed and Confused
set in 1980 the film follows a group of
college baseball players in the days
before class starts there's not really
much of a plot as the film focuses
instead on the relationships between
these jocks competitive dudes who spend
their days guzzling beer battling each
other and bonding over ball games it's
extremely funny while also examining the
mechanics of American masculinity
baseball having a tail cereal hunt for
the wilderbe afore signing on to direct
for Ragnarok New Zealand native Taika
Waititi gave us brilliant gems like what
we do in the shadows but the man really
topped himself with 2016's hunt for the
wilderness fits on the run from ninjas
dire wolves in an overzealous child
welfare agent who thinks she's the star
of an American cop show
whitey T's visuals are breathtaking and
the film expertly jumps back and forth
between gut-busting comedy and
tear-jerking sadness in short this is
one majestical movie the nice guys
written and directed by Shane Black who
redefined the buddy-cop film with Lethal
Weapon 2016's the nice guys is one of
the best entries in the genre in recent
memory which stars Ryan Gosling and
Russell Crowe bouncing off each other
like bloody boozy versions of Laurel and
Hardy whether they're getting into
gunfights interrogating witnesses or
discussing near-death experiences
involving Richard Nixon Gosling and
Crowe make the perfect comedy team and
really we totally wouldn't mind seeing
these actors reunite somewhere down the
line that would actually be pretty nice
guys
pop star never stop never stopping
straight from the incredible minds of
the Lonely Island 2016's pop star never
stopped never stopping attempts to do
for pop music what this is spinal tap
did for heavy metal and it succeeds
delivering a spot-on hilarious
mockumentary featuring Andy Samberg
as a former boyband star who finds
success as a solo act only to learn
being a loner isn't all it's cracked up
to be jam-packed with some fantastically
funny tunes
it also features cameos from musicians
like Usher Mariah Carey and an amazing
Justin Timberlake know who's in that
fish costume that was amazing the fish
was me by the time the credits roll we
guarantee you'll want to jump out of
your seat and start doing the donkey
roll thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our YouTube
channel let's check out all this cool
stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]